je crois qu'il faut être dans ce débat
prendre de la hauteur et être
responsable il faut avoir le courage de
dire la vérité que dit le corps avec les
phrases que vous sortez un peu de leur
contexte le président du corps qui est
intervenu à l'Assemblée nationale dit
oui les deux pans sont tenables mais il
rajoute dans la phrase d'après qui n'est
jamais passée d'ailleurs en disant mais
les retraites vont baisser les retraites
vont baisser donc il y aura un équilibre
mais les retraites vont baisser moi ce
que je souhaite c'est que ce régime de
répartition qui fait que ceux qui
travaillent aujourd'hui
paix la retraite de ceux qui ont
travaillé hier qui eux-mêmes ont payé la
retraite de ceux qui ont travaillé
avant-hier c'est le général de Gaulle
qui l'a voulu c'est un système qui est
juste c'est un système de solidarité
générationnelle et bien demain il va
être rompu parce que en 2050 le dernier
salaire sera trois fois supérieur à la
retraite si on reste dans le système
actuel et c'est ça qui sera profondément
juste parce qu'il y a des gens qui
auront travaillé toute une vie et qui
n'auront plus un niveau de retraite
décent donc moi je pense aussi au
maintien de cet équilibre et il faut
avoir aujourd'hui le courage de dire que
si on ne réforme pas le système on y
arrivera pas